[Müzik]
Aşkın Aldı
ama gereksiz
oldu
[Müzik]
ama seni
ben
yarım
[Müzik]
Muhammed
yok
[Müzik]
yürü emanet ol
git başka
ne
[Müzik]
aşkım
artar
[Müzik]
oldum
Yunus dur
[Müzik]
ur
İmge
[Müzik]
son iki
kişi
davası
[Müzik]
gelirsin
bir
[Müzik]
gece
bana
[Müzik]
seni
[Alkış]
panosu Kübra bana
dostluk Kipa buna
sunu tavuğuna hep diyor
mihi Ha Mila
panos'tu Kiram Anam panosu
tavuğuna
panos'tu ki bu tavuğuna pek
tisiz
[Müzik]
ne rak
ik
miskina pet Aman Aman biz gene pek
komuta
Kelo
riske nafak Aman Aman biz
de
nafizomuna kop
maraşo menopdun kel
ocanizan aman
yeni satılan
[Müzik]
bir zatuna bir
merak etti
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Aman Arzu Vurma Beni ben bu dağlar
Babamlara
[Müzik]
Vurma Beni ben bu Doğanay babam var
oğlum Avcı vurmuş ay babam yaram
acımıyormuş ay babam yar
[Müzik]
alı
Bir taş attım çaya düştü Çardak bir çift
ay balam Tur
nam Bir Taş Attım şaya düştü
Kaybol babam Turn
Benim gönlüm
sene Düştüm Senin gönlün ay Babam yine
düşsün
Sen Hep senin gönlün ay babam kim
şu dağlarda
[Müzik]
O Yar Benden Ay Balam Fener Gezer Oyar
benden Ay Balam fena
gez lan kenar Gezer
[Alkış]